merci merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la Culture depuis le 2 septembre
dernier le groupe Canal+ a cessé de
diffuser les cinq chaînes du groupe TF1
à la suite d'un différents commercial
concernant le renouvellement du contrat
de leur distribution la justice a eu
l'occasion de se prononcer à deux
reprises sur ce différent qui pénalisent
tout particulièrement les foyers situés
en zone rurale et en zone de montagne et
qui reçoivent la télévision numérique
par satellite en considérant que la loi
ne crée aucune obligation à la charge de
Canal+ de reprise des chaînes de la TNT
et que aucun contrat écrit signé avec le
groupe TF1 n'obligeait Canal+ à mettre à
disposition ces chaînes la cour d'appel
de Paris a certes clarifier la situation
du point de vue du droit mais elle n'a
pas résolu les difficultés rencontrées
par des millions de Français
le gouvernement est resté très discret
depuis deux mois sur cette situation
tandis que l'arcome qui a proposé
plusieurs fois sa médiation estime
qu'elle n'a pas les moyens juridiques
d'imposer un compromis dans ces
conditions que comptez-vous faire madame
la ministre pour permettre aux Français
qui ont aujourd'hui privés d'accéder à
la TNT
[Applaudissements]